a 10 años de la catástrofe de fukushima
los homenajes se sucedieron en todo
japón en memoria de las más de 19 mil
víctimas del tsunami miles de personas
rezaron por los fallecidos y depositaron
flores en las costas de todo el país
mientras en tokio el primer ministro
japonés destacó la resiliencia histórica
nipona frente a la adversidad como motor
de la recuperación cuando iba y crotona
con antonio una nuestra nación ha
superado varios desastres que fueron
crisis nacionales no obstante nuestros
predecesores superaron todas las crisis
con valentía y esperanza
y mike uruguay séptimo la generación
actual está ahora decidida a seguir su
camino
joe al ct hablando de cara al monumento
en homenaje y de espaldas a las cámaras
las principales autoridades políticas
del país rindieron sus respetos a las
víctimas entre ellas estaba el emperador
naruhito que presidió su primer gran
acto desde su llegada al poder en 2019
con o sin zaino gb no estaba la magnitud
del daño provocado por el desastre es
tan profunda que el recuerdo inolvidable
de la tragedia aún persiste en mi mente
las heridas del tsunami y la posterior
crisis nuclear aún siguen abiertas a
pesar de que la onu asegurara en un
informe que no hay relación entre la
radiación y el aumento de casos de
cáncer en fukushima japón se comprometió
a seguir investigando y anunció la total
recuperación de la zona para 2031 una
década después más de 36 mil personas
todavía no pueden regresar a sus hogares
debido a la radiación